تشتعل المعارك بين المسلحين القبليين
المدعومين من الجيش الصومالي ومقاتلي حركه
الشباب المواليه للتنظيم القاعده في عده
بلدات وقرن في اقليم هيران وصدصومال الجيش
الصومالي تحدث عن مقتل اكثر من 100 عنصر
من حركه الشباب في المعارك الاخيره
بالاقليم واستعاده بلدات وقرى
الاستراتيجيه تتوسع رقعه المعارك التي
تشاركها احيانا طائره مسيره للقياده
الامريكيه في افريقيا دعما للجيش والقوات
المحليه قبائل بولايه الجنوب الغربي شمال
تنظموا الى العشائر الطائره وتقول انها
حملت السلاح لتحرير مناطقها من حركه شباب
التي تسيطر على مناطق واسعه من الجنوب
ووسط البلاد منذ 15 عاما
52 عاما واقسم بالله انني ساحاربهم جنتهم
محاربتهم هؤلاء يجب ان نفردهم اعتقنا
يؤكد مسؤول ولايه جنوب الغربي شومال انه
ولايته هم بعثت جزءا من الحرب الجاريه ضد
الحركه مشيرين الى ان المعركه في مناطقهم
ستحسن سريعا
وحمانت اوفرا وجهوا نداء الى الصوماليين
في اقليم جنوب غربيه الصومال ليس امامهم
سوى قتال عدونا المتمثل في حركه الشباب
قمنا بجوله في مناطق عده بالاقليم لتعبئه
الجميع لشني عمليه مشتركه لقتلها هؤلاء
وان نحذو حظو الاقاليم التي طردتهم
وتاتي هذه المعارك في وقت تعيش المناطق
عديده من البلاد حاله جفاف عريمن يعد
القسوه منذ 40 عاما عبد الرحمن البخاري
العربيه مقديشو